good morning John I've given up on a hat
so the way that you're watching this
video right now is through two things
one is waves in sound uh so that's an
important part of the video the other is
waves in the electromagnetic spectrum
particularly in the part of the spectrum
that is visible light which turns out to
be a very narrow piece of the spectrum
now sound and light are very important
here on Earth there's a bunch of other
synthesis as well but when we start to
look at the universe the only tool we
have had to do astronomy with for the
entire history of humanity has been the
electromagnetic spectrum it's just been
photons when Galileo looked up and first
saw the moons of Jupiter he was looking
at visible light photons and when
Jocelyn Bell Bernell first saw the rapid
radio blinking of what turned out to be
Pulsar she was also looking at photons
or at least the telescope she was using
were looking at photons because we can't
see those photons in fact a lot of the
story of astronomy and thus the story of
how we understand like what's going on
around us has been the story of
expanding from the visible light
spectrum in into other wavelengths of
light we've just celebrated a year since
the first photos from jwst and each
superpower is being able to see in
further sections of the infrared which
is hard to do because anything that has
any heat is emitting infrared radiation
so in order to detect certain infrared
photons you have to be very cold because
otherwise the mirror itself that's
collecting the light is going to be
emitting a bunch of those photons into
the detector and thus washing out
whatever it is you might be able to
detect so there's infrared and
UltraViolet and x-rays and gamma rays
and microwaves and all these things all
this electromagnetic radiation gives us
different Clues into How the Universe
works we can see different stuff with
different wavelengths different events
make different kinds of light different
kinds of light are able to travel
through different objects more easily or
worse and thus we have learned all of
the things that we know about our
universe just by looking at this one
kind of thing but in the last decade and
especially in the last couple of months
we have got got two new ways to observe
our universe I don't really know if I
can express how big of a deal that is
it's like in the last 10 years having
Galileo look at the moons of Jupiter for
the first time twice now the first one
of these got pretty good press and I
talked a ton about it I was part of the
president God and it was very exciting
and it is gravitational waves ripples
Eden space-time that we are able to
detect have been able to detect for a
while but now we've got this new
extraordinarily powerful way of
detecting gravitational Waves by looking
at the timing of pulsars that are
distant in our galaxy basically turning
the entire galaxy into a giant
gravitational wave detector because when
there are waves in space time things
actually move a little bit closer or
further away like a meter per light year
but detectable because of how regular
pulsars are at flashing if they move a
little bit toward us we can actually
detect that which is wild it has allowed
us for the first time to detect the
gravitational wave background which is
extraordinarily cool but I had talked a
lot about it already but there is
another thing that's happened over the
last 10 years that had a huge
announcement like on the same weekend as
the gravitational wave announcement
which kind of is a shame game because it
got a little bit overshadowed and I want
to talk about it because of course I do
now certain high energy things that
happen in the universe or even low
energy things that happen in the
universe emit particles they emit
photons is one of the kinds of particles
they emit but also particles with mass
can be ejected like you get electrons
and you get like protons and pieces of
nuclei that's amazing but those things
get tossed all around and get absorbed
like crazy by the gas and dust in the
Galaxy so they're not very useful but
another kind of particle is also emitted
it's called a neutrino it's like an
electron but it's neutral like three
percent of the energy emitted by the sun
is emitted as neutrinos it's a lot like
there's a hundred trillion of them going
through you every second right now and
me and everyone but the thing is because
they are neutral and because atoms are
mostly empty space for the most part
neutrinos just fly right through stuff
and when I say for the most part I mean
basically all of them detecting
neutrinos has been a big deal in the
last you know Decades of science like
several Nobel prizes have been one about
this because when they do had a nucleus
of an atom things can happen detectable
things like some light can be emitted in
very weird situations one element can be
transformed into another element like
just one atom but it can happen so we've
had some ways of detecting neutrinos but
if we want to detect a lot of neutrinos
what you would need is a giant block of
an extremely transparent substance I'm
talking about like kilometers on a side
that had inside of it a bunch bunch of
detectors that could detect the light
created when a neutrino collided with a
nucleus but the substance we're talking
about would have to be like more
transparent than anything we've ever
created in a lab and so you would be
right to believe that there is no way to
create such a neutrino detector what
it turns out that deep down as Antarctic
snow gets compressed and compressed and
compressed it turns into a kind of ice
that is more transparent than anything
we have and also that ice is in an
extremely dark place because it's under
a bunch of other ice and snow so we have
on Earth I mean by chance because
Antarctica doesn't need to be there like
it does like it could just not be there
but it is so by chance we have on Earth
the perfect neutrino detector all we had
to do was drill a bunch of holes in it
with like hot water drills and then
lower instruments in to be able to
detect the slightest flashes of light
from neutrinos hitting Atomic nuclei and
we did that it's called and I love this
the Ice Cube neutrino Observatory and no
that doesn't stand for anything they
just called it ice cube because it's an
ice cube it's just a really big one it's
actually not a cube you don't care but
it's more like a hexagon no prism but
not exactly it's this shape but we are
not done with the problems yet so the
Ice Cube Observatory has detected over a
hundred thousand neutrino collisions
which seems like a lot it's not that
many when you considered that it's a
kilometer of ice and there's a hundred
trillion of them going through just your
body every second so it's a very small
percentage of the total neutrinos flying
through that Cube the other problem
though is the vast majority of those
neutrinos originated from within our
solar system they came from the Sun and
that's not that used what we want is the
neutrinos that are coming from our
galaxy and maybe even from other
galaxies that would allow us to see
things in our galaxy that we could never
see because of course photons get
absorbed by stuff like if you go in a
place that doesn't have a lot of light
pollution you can look up at the Milky
Way and you can see the clouds of dust
that are preventing the light from the
Milky Way to reach us that's what those
dark areas of the Milky Way are but
neutrinos are just gonna fly right
through that if we could map our galaxy
using neutrinos we could see stuff that
we've never been able to before but to
do that we have to separate out like the
99.9 percent of neutrinos that are
coming from the Sun from the ones that
are coming from our galaxy but to do
that we have to actually detect some of
those neutrinos coming from our galaxy
and there's far fewer of them but with
machine learning we are now able to do
it and we were thus able to use those
neutrino collisions to create the first
ever map of our galaxy that did not
depend on photons it's very low
resolution right now but as more time
passes more collisions are detected
hopefully we make this thing even better
at detecting neutrino Collision that map
will get more high resolution and this
Observatory this most bizarre of
telescopes this giant hexagonal prism of
ancient Antarctic ice under thousands of
meters of other ice are you serious this
way of observing our galaxy is entirely
new it has more time passes and we get
better at the techniques collisions it's
going to tell us so much stuff about how
our galaxy works it could along with the
gravitational wave back background
information he could help us rewrite the
laws of physics and this is just the
beginning I mean the wild thing about
neutrinos is that they aren't like
photons they change because they're
particles so they can go different
speeds they can have different
characteristics and all those things
tell you stuff about where they came
from and what they've experienced along
the way and their experience thus gets
transferred into our experience our
experience and understanding of our
universe and how it works it has been
but continues to be just a remarkable
time in science John I'll see you on
Tuesday